the problem is to slice and dice the
human brain so that we get all the
connections of the human brain map so
what we're lacking are volunteers
give us a time frame when do you think
we can map the human brain well I think
it would probably take a few more
decades before we can map every single
neuron of the human brain because
there's a hundred billion 100 billion
neurons each neuron connected to 10 000
of the neurons in the human brain but
once it's done then the quantum computer
can easily begin to manipulate it so the
problem is not the quantum computer the
problem is to slice up the human brain
slice and dice the human brain so that
we get all the connections of the human
brain map so what we're lacking are
volunteers
that's really the problem here brain